[موسيقى]
لم يخطر ببال أي يوم أن ينافس هذا
عندما صعدت الملكة إليزابيث الثانية إلى
العرش في أوائل الخمسينيات من القرن الماضي ، كانت بريطانيا
القوة المهيمنة في الشرق الأوسط ، وكانت
معظم البلدان على هذه الخريطة
محميات بريطانية دول قومية تشكلت حديثًا
مثل العراق والأردن واليمن.  كانت ملزمة
بالمعاهدات التي مارست بريطانيا
قدرًا هائلاً من السيطرة والتي
غالبًا ما كانت موضع نزاع
بينما كانت دول الخليج مثل عمان والبحرين
والإمارات العربية المتحدة التي كانت تُعرف آنذاك
باسم الدول الحاسمة في الغالب
راضية عن الوجود البريطاني
وسرعان ما أصبحت الملكة إليزابيث
وجهًا مألوفًا في الوسط.  الشرق تقوم
بأول زيارة دولة لها إلى المنطقة في
ليبيا بعد عامين فقط من توليها
رئاسة الدولة
، كما تم التقاط صور لها بجانب
أمير البحرين الشيخ أحمد
بن عيسى الخليفة الشيخ عبد الله بن
جابا والأب المؤسس لدولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة
الشيخ زايد بن نيان.
ولكن وراء كل هذه الابتسامات كانت هناك
حركة متنامية من أجل استقلال
بريطانيا كانت مسؤولة عن نمو
المنطقة م  AP في الوقت الذي جاءت فيه الملكة إليزابيث
في وقت كانت فيه تلك الخريطة
تواجه تحديًا في تلك الفترة
، كانت المنطقة منخرطة في مجموعة
واسعة من النضالات ضد
الانتفاضات ومحاولات
الإطاحة
بهذه الهيمنة البريطانية ، نجحت المحاولات
بحلول عام 1971 ، وبحلول عام 1971
كانت آخر بقايا من  اختفى الاستعمار البريطاني
في الشرق الأوسط ،
لكن الزيارات بين الملكة إليزابيث
وحكام المنطقة لم تتوقف
بشكل خاص مع أولئك الموجودين في
مجلس التعاون الخليجي أو دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي حيث
لم يُنظر إلى إرث بريطانيا على أنه
غير مرغوب فيه كما هو الحال في أجزاء أخرى من
الشرق الأوسط.  من زيارات الدولة
أو غيرها من الزيارات رفيعة المستوى
للعائلة المالكة البريطانية إلى دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
، فهي بهذا الحجم يمكن مقارنتها بزيارات
العائلة المالكة
إلى عوالم الكومنولث التي شكل أفراد
الأسرة الحاكمة والملكية في دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
علاقات حقيقية مع
أعضاء  العائلة المالكة في بريطانيا
والتي تؤدي إلى روابط تجارية كبيرة ،
روابط ثقافية كانت
تلك الروابط أيضًا  مشتركة
مع العائلات المالكة خارج الخليج
مثل الأردن على الرغم من كونها محمية بريطانية سابقة ،
لكن بالنسبة لبعض مواطني المنطقة ،
فإن الملكية هي رمز
للحكم الاستعماري البريطاني الذين يلومونهم على
مظالمهم الحالية ،
فهناك العديد من الأشخاص في العالم العربي
الذين لا يفعلون ذلك.  ليس لديهم استياء خاص
تجاه الملكة أو ملك إنجلترا الحالي ،
لكنهم بالتأكيد
لا يوافقون
على أه السياسة الاستعمارية البريطانية لأنها
ألحقت خسائر فادحة
بأهالي المنطقة ، حيث كانت أعلى مرتبة تراثية عالية
فوق كل شيء آخر في عهد الملكة إليزابيث.
خضع النفوذ البريطاني في الشرق الأوسط
لتغيير كبير حيث
تلاشت الهياكل الاستعمارية
وتشكلت شراكات إستراتيجية
استمرت حتى يومنا هذا وكانت الزيارة
الأخيرة للخليج على ما أعتقد إلى عمان
أه حيث زارت البحيرة أه السلطان
سلطان
كابوس وإذا أخذت  انظر إلى
الصور وسترى الشعور الحقيقي
بالمودة والصداقة بين هذين
الاثنين  الملوك عميق ، إنه ذو مغزى
، بريطانيا الحقيقية أعتقد أنها أكثر من
مجرد حليف استراتيجي ، إنها
عائلة لجلالته
بينما يغلق هذا الفصل الحاسم من التاريخ البريطاني فصلًا
آخر قد
يزدهر قريبًا حيث كان يعلم أن الملك تشارلز الثالث
يتطلع إلى المنطقة للبناء
من العلاقات التي كانت والدته تزرعها